[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to
just kidding no no off the record damn
it's been a while
it's my first day back from the
breakfast oh man okay i kept calling a
podcast
it's whatever we want here uh so welcome
back to off the record where we talk
about
whatever we want and uh
geo you're sporting a new look oh yes so
i decided to just kind of
throw a little splash of color in my
hair um funny enough it was going to be
one of those where i either go bald
ball you mean it's actually it was like
your head where were you getting your
ears
what do you think of that so there's
obviously two sides right
where uh the the first supportive side
is like i don't give a [ __ ] whatever
makes you happy go do you go make
yourself
that's the boring side what's the other
side so the other real side
the real side is like like let's see if
i'm doing doggy style i don't want to
see
just a ball yeah he doesn't want to
feel like he's [ __ ] a skinhead in
jail yeah i'm like i don't want to do
that
you're not a freak and then and then
like you know if you're like kissing
them all touching like a [ __ ] fade
and [ __ ] i'm like i don't know
nice that would feel as you're like
making up thank you
you know when you get your hair cut you
just feel the back of your head but now
you can do it in this direction
i don't know are you trying to grab her
hair and she's like wait hold on
that reminds me because she did have the
side of the head shave did you ever like
touch the side of that did you ever
cover it
and then touch it no that one's
different because most of it is still
long long hair yeah so it balanced it
out did you avoid the side of the hair
then you're like
i'm just gonna hold the long hair no no
that because there's still long enough
hair
would you just like flip her hair over
so she has hair on
this side too i think it's mainly the
top
so like if you if you shave this side i
think you're ridiculous if we shave this
side i think i'll still be cool and if
you shave the back and all the way
around but it's still long it still
looks like long hair if it falls down
but if she only shaved it to the top
here
oh yeah what if she does a samurai where
she where she cuts
just this and then the side is she has
long sleeves better than a shaved head
fully
why did you still wear a hat and you
would still look like you had hair
yes yeah but you got to remember my
first
uh my first choice was i was very
supportive
wait but my whole thing was i thought
okay i would think
my first thought is if gio wanted to
shave her head it's because she wanted a
collection of 50 wigs
to try out different looks and it'll be
easier than to
put a wig on with hair that's that's
what i'll be like oh yeah that makes
sense why she would shave her head yeah
that's the real question why did you
want to go so extremely so
i think i think about a lot of things
all at once so there's a lot of things
that i admire and i look at and i'm like
oh that's tight that's tight and there's
so many things i want to experience
especially after 2020
um i'm like [ __ ] all that like [ __ ] what
people think
[ __ ] what anyone thinks i've like
embraced this like
new [ __ ] solid geo where i'm like so
selfish true
everything so it's one of those where
i'm like let's [ __ ] go so that's i
didn't even really care what bart had to
say
no offense but it was just one of those
where i'm like i could date a skinhead
[ __ ] it so
you have to be married um
but yeah it's one of those that i just
think about all the time so when i
finally commit to it there's no
real like i can't walk you through my
thought process because it's been
happening for so long that's how i felt
about my hair too huh
oh like that's how i felt about my
colored hair too where people were like
like oh what does casey think about it
or like what about isaac
what does he care i'm like [ __ ] i don't
even consider them at all good
that's tight you don't have color
anymore or do you she got rid of it all
died out
she's not a mermaid no more no that's
what i thought
more people have like [ __ ] to say about
a woman's look from both women
and men than guys like if we look
disgusting and sloppy
like they're like haha you're [ __ ]
stupid and
and that's it right but then like for
women like you get attacked by both
sides
oh yeah there's so many [ __ ] opinions
i don't know why oh yeah
it's also really interesting too because
then when someone that has like colored
hair or like just like
dressing more pattern whatever it is
right like other people
have to have the thought in their mind
where it's like oh she's calling out for
attention
because that's what happened when i had
my colored hair too people would be like
oh so you must love the attention i'm
like
what the [ __ ] like i didn't even
consider that there's so much insecurity
in the world
yeah the most uh i get is from men
that's it
no girl tells me like you should do this
with your body your hair or anything
it's all guys that are like why are you
growing your hair this way why do you
have that shirt on why
i'm like oh my god what are you trying
to suck my dick
like what you thinking why do you care
so bad
yeah damn it's it's weird because i
never think that like from guy to guy i
never go like uh
like why do you have that shirt yeah i'm
just like what the [ __ ]
it doesn't matter i'm not trying to [ __ ]
you speaking of dicks
speaking of dick sucking i was listening
to uh dmx what's my name
and i didn't realize how gangster this
fool was so there's this one lyric
where he goes suck my because you know
what the the flow is goes
so he goes suck my dick and he goes if
y'all
been in jail y'all you know it gets
thick
i'm like oh [ __ ] he's telling dudes to
do it
he wasn't telling chicks dumb like this
is that's a next level gangster because
i've never
even like explored have you listened to
his christmas song he has a christmas
oh yeah the rudolph he had the cover of
room
it's so good i was listening to him so
much this holiday because i was like
this sounds like it's like a parody but
he's so serious because he's like
rudolph the red nose brandon so you said
that you mentioned you mentioned that
you
do judge other guys for what they i mean
yeah i'm not going to tell it to their
face
both to my face what's the thought
process i think no no no no no but
what's the thought process behind it
like just like you could do better you
know like you look at somebody and i'm
just like dude
this nasty white t-shirt and this like
terrible or more like
more like actual like stylistic choices
for example like
with casey getting his hair permed there
was a lot of people that had their
opinions
mainly guys what are they saying like i
don't know what were they were they
calling you gay
yeah i don't know i think it's always
good to like
try a little bit so even if like your
style is [ __ ] crazy
right it's like if someone's like doing
something that they're feeling or
they're trying it's like
that's sick you're doing something but
sometimes don't judge people for that
no i think in my head a lot of times
when people i think i think it's more of
an idea of like people getting lazy and
sloppy about
who they are and how they put themselves
forward like after a while i feel like
it's kind of like uh
when people have been married for a long
time and people just start to let
themselves go
get comfortable it's like that but to
the world
you know what i mean i'm like you could
try a little oh i get i get it it's kind
of like maybe put on something without
pissing that makes sense
so it's like how america is viewed by
the rest of the world especially like in
europe like europe
it's like having a dirty yard and it's
like come on dude like
yeah clean it up it's not like i judge
into the part where i'm like dude that's
disgusting
clean yourself up i'm like in my own
head i'm like you could try more
oh but you don't tell them to they're no
like yeah yeah do whatever you want with
your own [ __ ] life do you comment on
instagram
no like i don't like that i'm like you
can do whatever you want with your life
i'm not gonna like
interrupt whatever you're trying to do
but in my own head i can still be like
you could try a little bit i think
that's very different from um
carrying a human being because you think
that they should dress the way that you
want them to right
right like their stylistic choice is
wrong rather than just not having a
stylistic choice whatsoever
yeah yeah you can do it whatever you
want i still can't believe people were
commenting about your perm i don't even
i didn't he didn't know either
there was one that caught my attention
because it was the first comment on on a
post and they were like
what's wrong with your messy hair or
something like that it looks dope
i think that was my point
and they get messy yeah i don't know
yeah like that but i do agree
if they think that it looks uh a little
more feminine
i think my face structure with this hair
does give it a more
feminine appeal i can tell the
difference i was trying to go for any
feminine appeal like more women like it
uh no no no no i like k-pop stars you
know like
an old face that it's not very like a
feminine
kind of face that i would say it would
make you know i don't know what it is
but when i look at my own reflection in
the mirror i'm like
ah okay so you look way more feminine
now i don't know what why
like american standards i guess yeah
yeah like americans look at k-pop stars
and they're like
who are these like effeminate like
little girls you know yeah but then like
i feel like a lot of like
asians they get hella k-pop [ __ ] [ __ ]
i guess
yeah yeah yeah and a [ __ ] and c [ __ ]
and
sort of [ __ ] i feel like i don't know
man they called prince
a feminine person and he was banging the
hottest girls ever [ __ ] yeah
like who cares you kind of have that too
huh
he kind of has a problem too does he
or she i don't know this i don't know
because i feel like she did
and then he curved it oh yeah michael
jackson too for sure
he straightened and then curvy
brightened it and redid it again i think
does that mean that i'm ugly then
cause it's when i get lean right
everyone goes
i miss fat bart why they want you for
everyone
the other way it's not for life because
you look funnier
and they they enjoy laughing at you yeah
i think a lot of
like comedy people you want them to look
terrible right
oh like jonah hill yeah he got ripped
though you look good
yeah i don't get in the time he's
funnier when he's fat really
i don't i don't understand it i never i
mean david is a good example
well i think with jonah hill
specifically when he lost all the weight
he just had like this chip on his
shoulder
every time he was like acting or being
interviewed like he just came off more
like he was hungry he looked mean
like he was angry his eyes was more
sunken in he also started taking more
serious roles didn't he very mean
yeah yeah like that one 80s dystopian
kind of
weird one on netflix what was that one
80's dystopia yeah it was kind of like
you choose your own
i forgot what it was it was like you
choose your own path thing yeah it was
pretty cool like black mirror
and bandersnatch yeah i thought that was
him no that's not him
is there another one where it's kind of
80s [ __ ] stranger things
no he's not in stranger things i don't
think i've ever seen a skinny jonah hill
in a movie he's only been in commercials
i feel like when he was skinny
i feel like i've seen him in movies i
think so i don't know i don't know
speaking of entertainment let's talk
about my favorite way to be entertained
in the car and this episode of off the
record is brought to you by audible
so the last book i was listening to was
um this is not a shirt by bobby hundreds
he's like a good friend of ours and
he's just a very inspiring person in
like the brand building
and streetwear space and one thing that
i really
uh noticed that's a huge difference
between reading a book and then also
listening
to audiobook especially when the author
is the one that is narrating
you really get to hear the emotion and
almost like the history
and the inspiration of why they wrote
the book
so it's way different than when you read
a book and it's
in your own words and then sometimes you
kind of interpret it in the tone that
you want so that's like one of my
favorite things
and now that i'm so true sorry to
interrupt you but that's so true because
i was listening to the last black
unicorn by tiffany haddish like that was
one of my first
yeah yeah yeah yeah that i listened to
and i just loved hearing the emotion in
her voice as she was telling the story
of her own life
it's a completely different experience i
agree yeah was bobby
reading his own book reads his own book
yeah and he does like a great job and he
talks about his childhood
his upbringing and all that and you
really feel
like that much more connected to the
book which was i never thought it'd be
like that i was thought a physical book
could be more connected but
yeah you it almost feels like he's
talking to you the whole time that
you're driving so i really love that
so if you guys don't know what audible
is audible is the leading provider of
spoken word entertainment and audiobooks
ranging from bestsellers and new
releases to celebrity memoirs languages
business motivation
and more like original entertainment and
now podcast
2. recently we've just launched our
newest plan audible plus with audible
plus you get
full access to plus catalog which is
filled with thousands and thousands of
select originals audiobooks and podcasts
including ad-free versions
of popular shows as well as exclusive
series audible plus connects you to
tons of content that entertains inspires
and informs
and it's easy to find just the right
listen whether it's comedy romance
suspense true crime science fiction or
fitness and
wellness you can even squeeze in a
workout or guided meditation without
having to go to gym
or class and with everything you want to
listen to all in one app
audible plus can truly become your
playlist for life
okay guys if you want to go grab this
visit audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500-500 to start your free
30-day trial that's a whole month
free nice damn quote i know they had
audible plus now i'm gonna have to
upgrade
my account yeah i just had regular
audible i gotta do it now
and it's pretty cool code what's the
code
audible.com off the record or text
off the record to 500-500
so we talked about just your hair but
what about the rest of your outfit like
your your jacket
your crazy pattern i think i've kind of
always been kind of crazy
uh like this i think i kind of toned it
down for a couple years that looks
really cool
the movie reference the romeo and juliet
thing it really worked because your
actual outfit looks like it belongs in
the movie thank you
so so i remember you mentioning
something similar to this when you first
got your tattoos like years ago
you were like yeah i had to do this
because like i want to be like
man [ __ ] what people say essay you know
yeah and then like she's like on the
route she's like [ __ ] it yeah you could
take the girl out of them
so that tells me that
you know i mean just to just for people
that are watching out there that it's an
ongoing journey
and it's not something that you do one
thing and then all of a sudden you're
just like
i wake up and now it's all gone like you
still
you're still uh i don't know if battling
is the right word but you're still
trying to figure out like constantly
reinventing
unapologetic yeah well i don't know if
it's a battle it's more um
i just realized i became my own muse and
then
now that i've embraced that and i
realized that i'm just having so much
[ __ ] fun and i'm like what else can i
do let's go
so it's just kind of that vibe now
whereas before it was more like i felt
really trapped
because i had such a strict upbringing
and then i was finally
free and i had money to do [ __ ] and i'm
like let's go [ __ ] wild
you know but now this time i'm like oh
[ __ ] i'm like a canvas and i could like
paint myself every day like let's party
i recently saw this um video of this
like
old lady she was like maybe in her 60s
or something right and then she's like
she dresses like she she she bought
clothes at hot topic or like pacsun
did she wear big glasses about about
you're too old to be dressing like a
teen you saw that one oh i didn't see
that yeah and then i'm like
she looks good like why do people
[ __ ] care so much
about dressing age appropriate doing
this
and like i'm like why do why does it
[ __ ] matter why is there so many hall
monitors
yeah that's true it doesn't make any
sense to me because like for me i
definitely have felt a change in my own
personal style where i'm like
i don't feel so comfortable wearing like
crop tops or what even though this is
kind of cropped up but like but you're
like i'm a mom now i'm too old for this
[ __ ]
like well i've always been a mom since i
was 18.
jewel for this yeah i've always had the
mom factor
but no like now i actually do feel like
well
i'm 31 i don't feel at like myself i
don't feel as comfortable
dressing how i used to dress so now i do
still have some of the same clothes so
i'll still wear them but like i do
feel myself regulating yourself from
that
style and like moving more towards like
a different
type of style where i feel more
comfortable or more like me i guess
you don't want to be a hoochie anymore
yeah i guess and i think that's dope and
i think it should go for everyone that
has left the comment on anyone's page to
like give your two cents about like
um like why are you doing that while
you're doing that it's like
people just evolve differently and
people come in to their own conclusions
and in their own space like for her
she's like pulling back but for me i'm
like
[ __ ] going in the opposite direction
and i think both are yeah and both
are perfectly fine i want to show my
thong on the side like
this wrong yeah even you you're up in
your game
uh yeah i'm exploring i think that
i've always enjoyed fashion though just
like here and there and i explored with
stuff throughout my childhood
but it's just um i just get into things
you know it's not
really uh a thing like oh i gotta prove
this or i think i've always not give a
[ __ ] what other people wanted
it's always been what i wanted right so
at the moment
if i don't care about clothes and i care
about something else like let's say i
care
about bikes i don't give a [ __ ] about
what i wear at that moment
yeah and then maybe um something will
click
because like i'm like oh yeah that
shirt's dope and maybe it'll go
good with these pants and then like i
build off of that
so i'm more impulsive and there's not
much of
a strong like strategy
yeah yeah it's more like a feeling that
i follow gotcha i think i think uh for
me
i think i really just enjoy brand
building so i think
like i see myself as a brand so like
it's just exciting to just build on that
so it's not necessarily a feeling either
it's just more like
build on that like yeah it's like one
thing leads to another
and then it might kind of fall off for a
moment and then you do something else
but then
you build up like your fashion bars
because now it's natural to you right
yeah versus like having this like
overwhelming goal
of like i want to be the best [ __ ]
jacket designer
yeah yeah it doesn't it doesn't happen
like that in my mind i'm just kind of
like
i follow one thing i like that and i
keep going and i keep going and i'm like
oh yeah i've always liked vintage [ __ ]
how come i didn't like get more into it
kind of like that yeah that is cool you
know what also
because i'm sitting here thinking about
it too i'm like why is it that i feel
like moving away from a certain type of
thing and i think it's also because my
body's changing as i'm getting older too
you got a beer belly now i don't have a
beer
i've definitely gotten thicker and over
the years and i think a good way or a
bad way or
happier personally it's a good way to
give it away
good answer i've always been way too
underweight
and now i feel like i'm at the perfect
way oh because i'm not used to being
a bigger size like now i feel like
different about how i dress myself
i guess so that is another factor that i
think plays
i know how that feels because i remember
i used to really like break dancing
in junior high and then i tried to break
dancing
like in college just [ __ ] around and
i'm like [ __ ] my center of gravity is
way up
you're used to like you know when you're
like i don't know like 4 11
and like 80 pounds you're just spinning
around i remember doing all kinds of
crazy
[ __ ] and then now like even falling off
a snowboard just even a little bit
like 200 pounds falling on the ground
hurts a lot yeah i'm like
[ __ ] i don't have the 80-pound body in
the morning when i was playing
in uh the [ __ ] play play place
at mcdonald's with isaac i don't like
that
because i was still trying to be a
little kid with my kid jumped in the
ball pen
no not on the ball and you got stuck
tubes in the actual clip
oh that [ __ ] hurts now yeah it hurts my
knees
like oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you